meet Kimi Werner a free diver from
Hawaii who loves him catch her own lunch
and when she was out catching her lunch
one day off the coast of Mexico a great
white shark swam by
to my surprise I let out a squeal and I
started swimming towards her
I can't tell whether it's bravery or
just sheer stupidity
everyone knows you don't just approach a
great white and shake its big great
white sharks are formidable predators
they can be up to 16 feet or 5 metres
long
their teeth are serrated and so they're
basically for ripping and shredding in
addition to that they have incredible
senses a great sense of smell great
sense of vision a great sense of hearing
and this extra sense that fish have
which allows them to detect electrical
signals in the water so they're very
efficient hunters so why isn't this 142
because we are not his usual prey when a
great white does attack a human it's
likely because it is mistaking a human
for a seal or a sea lion most great
white shark attacks occur in that
context
it's obviously incredibly dangerous so
why can Kimmi hitch a ride and the great
white
she hasn't just been Cavalier and left
into the water she's able to read the
signs clearly enough to choose the time
that it's best to swim with them
the shark is swimming calmly his
pectoral fins aren't down and there
isn't any other hunting going on nearby
in the water so this shark isn't about
to attack